Legend
Knight FC Knight f60 4g6 Knight bd2 you
want to play uh if obviously D5 minus
did that already but more for happy than
Blitz Castle so what did he do queen
takes C5 I played C4 okay ah immediately
three and then and then C4 and the point
is obviously that he is expecting to
take C4 so he doesn't even want to spend
the temp on which pizza and why is he
expecting I mean E4 I guess is a bit
annoying before C5 potentially change
the strength okay maybe as a guess yeah
okay and uh yeah
some more trades have happened you have
like played Knight C6 and yeah I
actually quite like what Mark about
doing
well I do like the Greenland Mississippi
was on F6
I think I would assume Blake is already
completely fine yeah but again on V6 I
mean equivalent to check is going to be
annoying Bishop d55 like we need to
check something like this because you
you never really want to play F6 and you
never really want to play King G8 either
your position feels a bit unstable but
yeah I think it's more or less entirely
because the queen is sidelined if if
that Queen wasn't a good Square
these types of positions you generally
feel like you shouldn't be losing them
you know to be to be that good but yeah
it's again I'm very interesting no no
this is just like like Peak magnets
he just goes Bishop into here doesn't
even want to travel to travel himself
with Bishop D5 okay just drops it back
you know you know why I think because
there's A5 here
and it's uh liquidates uh a lot of I
mean at least one pawn and if you go be
shopping to A5 now you have B5
absolutely yeah and Knight D5 and queen
Beetle and um that's a good point yeah
it's extremely ugly but can we try
playing let's say you go
okay I mean it's a position so I go I go
I go check out yeah okay yeah I go so
let's have to roxy2 I I understand how
ugly it looks but can I try playing a
5v5 man V8
and try to trade everything along the C
file and also give myself exactly I want
to give at least one piece of mine a
good Square I can look forward to you
know like
um
at least improve one piece okay yeah
it's frozen oh yeah no it is good 97
checks I have to understand it it does
lose yes
it played they played very similarly to
what we're discussing hey five so it
didn't ignore just he acknowledge yeah
probably afraid of G4 yeah Knight B8 95
uh-huh okay that's clever because no I
don't know if it's clever or not but
97 and he no no yeah
once again if that Queen was on some
kind of a normal Square I would assume
this is nothing but it's just
it continues being cut off from
everything
that's actually interesting I'm a bit
worried for uh for Marco here because
yeah he's he's basically playing sort of
a queen a queen down a little bit
a little bit yeah I mean of course it
will it will come back at some point but
maybe
it looks looks incredibly dangerous yeah
no no it looks just bad
um oh it took College five whoa okay
that probably is
the beginning of the end yeah super
shocking but just a panic move probably
didn't see what to do against H6 and so
on yeah
okay so let's let's look at this
position I guess if we want to play the
end game we probably played with the
Knights on so I take only five and taken
F7 with a knight maybe yeah I was
considering something 95 Maybe
but only a knight of six
uh
this is still very very dangerous
yeah yeah I can I can drive it to V1 and
then play Rook C7 and yes that was my
plan yeah like group C3 it might be one
or two seven it's still better but the
Rooks are gone
and with the Rooks gone and the queen
Now sort of rejoining the game it feels
like
we have to win this game technically now
we're not going to be giving mate
my first big question we have here is
are we playing B6 yeah
like it it feels like well he started
with Community though very interesting
so he is saying
uh well basically he's saying I couldn't
find a way to make B6 work so I'm
allowing you to play V6
okay B6 will come I guess probably quite
quickly yeah you have to like the moment
it's allowed you have to do it
yeah okay yeah it's a good point a bit
confused yeah ah because Queen D4
yeah interesting
for a while
okay so you you know your pupil you have
to calculate takes the x22 I don't know
if this is so great but
maybe we just go we should perform and
we have green default check
yeah so it works out
he played yeah it's like he played E4
here
okay breaking everything up
oh boy what's wrong with 90 I mean it
feels like something went wrong but
is kind of a strange choice but
yeah and now we just go in and give
mates on how 95 probably is a good start
it's a disaster yeah this doesn't feel
like you you ever stabilize here
can I start with screen for check by the
way sure King just seven ninety five no
no yeah this probably is clear I think
yeah if you go Knight F6 then I go check
then we go back yeah and then very clean
yeah that's what he played yet been a
four played King just haven't played
kill plane 95 Queen E5 check is also
yeah I mean not we're never allowing
that to six no no you can get fat you
can still come back yeah
I guess you can go 95 now I think the
important square that we needed to stop
was D4 now that Queen D4 is not
available I think this probably just
wins very comfortably
yeah
yeah it's a
oh it's wait wait wait wait wait I guess
I just got 95 next move and we give the
same mate exactly yeah it doesn't really
matter all that much
Knight F6 it's still confusing to me
frankly but I mean he knows what he's
doing
maybe 96 we got this page five yeah
instead of 95. maybe in this way King G7
appears to be okay okay let me let me
let me see whoa yeah okay I missed that
okay I'll probably you know I'll
probably still winning I mean yeah this
is not a horrible I mean like nothing
can go on ever yeah I mean that is so
dominant that yeah it really doesn't
matter what you do but
yeah I would have I would have gone from
age but you know he clearly isn't really
spoiling anything here no the way the
way he's playing Queen G3 how did it go
Queen G3 King F5 Queen H3 Queen G4 which
would be six is twice way way too fast
sorry sorry Queen G3 Queen G3 oh yeah
the Magnus way final position yeah no
actually okay
I know what here is
but then my tcc's actually trades Queens
latex ah yeah in trade Queens yeah and
you can give a check from C3 she won an
H6
which is why I was so interested in
Queen C7
but then after Queen I go to G3 and I
start making queen of four checks
everywhere
Queen G6 here Queen G4
and I ended up actually trading quiz